we're gonna be focusing on lap palooka
offski now holiday yes is a very
interesting character in Soviet chess he
was born in Belarus which is pretty far
from the heart of the Soviet Union but
he became a very very strong player now
left Beluga offski was born in 1934 and
he didn't become a chess professional
until 1954 so he was already 20 which is
quite late by most standards even
players at the end of the 1900s sorry
the 1800s were already much younger
starting their professional chess
careers sao paulo JFC definitely started
late however he had a very serious
impact in chess
he would never want the World
Championship title and he never even
contended for it directly he was never
able to qualify for the World
Championship match but he was always
very close and he was always very strong
polo guy offski was three times Soviet
champion and he has wins against
Petrossian Smith love pal the Trojan I
mean just mention it if it's a world
champion on the 50s 60s or 70s he's won
he had a very long and productive chest
career in 1991 1991 he won a tournament
he sorry he got second in a tournament
in Reggio Emilia behind Karpov and
beating Chomsky so this is a guy that
was very productive throughout his
entire chest career he died in 1995 out
of a brain tumor and his style was kind
of eccentric it was difficult to pin him
down on what his style was but what he
was
was a hard worker Beluga ASCII was known
as one of the hardest-working truss
players and he had one of the most
vicious opening preparations in the
history of the game now we have to
understand the palooka ascii wasn't
around when frits and stock fish and all
this chess engines existed there was no
such thing as a chess computer so all
his analysis was done the good old
fashioned style he sat in front of the
board and he thought and he thought and
he thought and he used notebooks and he
would write down variations and he would
write down variations until he
discovered novelties and new ideas we're
going to start with one of the games
that seems like a very impressive
masterpiece but has a little twist at
the end we're going to look at the game
we're going to start with the game left
Beluga a ski against me Heil tall the
world champion from Riga and they are
playing in the 1969 Soviet championship
in Moscow I think that palooka a ski if
I'm not mistaken tied for first on this
one but lost the tiebreak to Petrossian
so I might I might I'm not a hundred
percent on that one but I think that's
correct and we're going to look at a
game that looks pretty interesting and
it starts c4 Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 net
of 3d 5d for C 5 and after takes takes
we get a variation of the tirage which
is not so common nowadays it's supposed
to be a little bit better for white but
you see it every blue moon once in a
while you'll see some top Grandmaster
employ it still mostly people recapture
here with the pawn on d5 which leads to
the main variations of the tarush
defense instead of that night xt5 was
played efore Knight takes c3 pawn takes
pawn takes pawn takes check and Bishop
d2 and all of this was known theory at
the time black accepts a space
disadvantage in the center in order to
change a few pieces and accelerate his
development he also says that
because he has no weaknesses it's not so
easy for white to develop any kind of
initiative now this why it's supposed to
be a little bit better no matter what so
castle's was played Bishop c4 was played
and then 9c six castles v6 looks very
standard development why developed also
quite standard with ruh KD one putting
his pieces in the center preparing some
kind of d5 break in the future advancing
his pawn they should be seven was played
and then rook everyone so so far it
seems like both sides of played quite
sensibly White has developed this pieces
blacks develop these pieces why it's
developed more has a little bit more
space black solid black it's difficult
to penetrate blacks position cool nine a
five we should retreat it to d3 the rook
went to c8 and now an interesting idea
by peluda ask if you play the move d5
which looks like it just blunders upon
right because this pawn doesn't have
sufficient defense so if for example I
take on d5 I can probably not take on d5
because the Queen would simply take on
d5 right instead palooka asked you have
the idea of playing d5 in order to play
e5 opening up this bishop while the pawn
sacrifice on d5 block this bishop out of
the game yes
he could after King takes h7 queen takes
d5 Bishop takes rook takes we have a
position in which we have equal material
and there's no real reason to believe
that white is better if anything I would
say that after oops sorry
after the move rook c2 maybe black is a
little bit better at the end materials
equal but this rook seems to be
harassing this pollinate to quite
successfully it's probably a little bit
better for black but you're right it's
playable but polio gaskey was having
none of that he wanted to attack so he
played g5 9 c4 was played and this
attacks the Queen now of course I don't
want to trade off my important bishop so
full of chaos he just moved the Queen
away and then tile came up with the move
Knight B - he Forks the bishop and the
rook trying to trade off some pieces
away from the attack so in this case
after Knight B to the more logical move
would be root D - the idea being that
after I take I take everybody is equal
material or black SAP upon but this
diffuses the attack on the King side
right there is no more Bishop attacking
that side of the board
so pulling IFC came up with the move
Bishop takes h7 check pretty cool pretty
standard but we'll see if it works
it's considered to be a Greek sacrifice
right or a Greek gift sacrifice yes
yes very good so after text 85 check now
of course we cannot go back to g8
because I think the easiest here is
Queen age 4 and black white simply wins
because there is no good defense against
the penetration of the Queen to h7 and
that starts the game that's it
so instead tile goes forward with this
King asking the question well what's
your next move
there doesn't seem to be anything
immediate at the moment there are no
checks and the black pieces are
attacking several things first of all
this rook still under attack it hasn't
moved and second this Queen is attacking
the knight on g5 right so it seems like
there's a lot of things hanging below
guess he didn't care he went h4 a
brilliant move it simply defends the
knight which looks like it's a loss of
Tempe but it's brilliant it brings also
the pawn into the attack and it makes
that King feel a little less secure
there's actually a particular idea about
this move the idea and it's kind of deep
is that after Knight takes D 1 which was
not played h5 check would win
immediately the point is that King h5
would be met by g4 check now notice that
if this game goes back ups this is very
sensitive if the King goes back to h6 I
play Knight takes f7 double check or
more accurately maybe night II 6 check
attacking the King and then the Queen
would fall right so why retains attack
at this up material so if the King moves
forward to h4 not only does it look
suicidal it is Knight f3 check King h3
Queen g3 checkmate if the King retreats
to g6
then check only move Quidditch King h6
check only move King takes g5 correct
check only move king f4 and checkmate on
f5 so the rock is poison he cannot take
the rook he doesn't have the time there
are alternatives here for white for
black however there is the idea of
playing f5 so as to have the f5 position
controlled but even here after rook
before White's attack is really strong
Queen d7 gets refuted by e6 but that's
another lecture it would be quite
complicated to show everything here but
it's not so good instead I'll play the
move rook c4 the idea being that in this
variations that we just considered there
is going to be a slight difference after
h5 check black does have the luxury of
playing the move Queen h6 because after
I discovered check with both pieces
right the King retreats I don't have the
time to take the Queen because rook
takes f4 so here Queen f5 check was
played the King retreated and notice how
it looks like the King's becoming safer
but it's actually not so 98 still fails
to rock f5 after which I think after
Knight takes p7 white might be lost
after Knight takes D 1 right because I
still have this rope hanging at the end
so instead
Beluga is key up the ante he made the
attack stronger an e6 came pretty strong
now I'm attacking I'm threatening e7 for
King the Queen and the rook right over
the pawn against 3 7 and I'm defending
the knight on 8
f7 at the moment Queen f6 is the only
move if Queen e7 then the move h6 is
lethal
notice that this lonely little pawn just
March up the board is actually
threatening h7 checkmate because this
Knight controls h8 right to h7 would be
checkmate in this position and there is
no good way of preventing this move
because if I take Queen g6 is also
checkmate therefore Queen f6 is best
trying to exchange the pieces below guy
F key was ok with that because after
rugby - even though he's still down a
piece and even though it seems like most
of the attack has died down this past
pawn on e6 and that this coordination of
black's pieces will cost him a severe
amount of material now being the strong
player that he has retreated his rook
but had he retreated the night then
after 96 he would have been completely
lost as this is it where am I here after
96 this would be completely devastating
as I'm attacking the bishop on b7 I'm
attacking the rook on c4 and I'm
training to pass the phone support it by
the night on e8 right so this will cause
black huge amounts of material instead
rook c6 was played but after rook takes
b2 black does have too many problems at
the moment White's up a pawn so out of
all the attack he got a pawn and his
Kings a lot safer the rest of the game
is not as flashy but still because of
the weekend King position black is
basically lost there is no good way of
defending against this route coming into
the seventh rank and the combination of
this powerful Knight this powerful rook
and again this pawn that wants to go to
the end
there is just no good way of defending
thing rook c6 was attempted rookie to
simply threatening to go rookie salmon
Bishop here check here Knight some night
maneuvers and then the rook took on a
seven and here towel resigned because
well he's down a pawn this is a threat
his Kings feeling weak everything's bad
so he resigned before further torture so
this looks pretty cool right Beluga yes
he sacrificed a piece and he had this
brilliant attack and the pawn came
forward and it just seemed cool right
this is the this is the type of games
that pal win tal wins like this this is
this is what how he did it
tal the magician of riga sacrificed all
his pieces on one that's a he won not
palooka ascii what's going on well
actually this is helpful guy xq1 gates
this position after moved 25 was
actually on palooka of skis board before
the game started he had prepared the
entire game all the sacrifice all
de-spawn pushing everything had been
analyzed before the game even started
this is home prep nowadays it's very
common that grandmasters go with a huge
amount of theoretical information so as
to not fall for tricks like this but
palooka ascii he was one of the he was
one of the hardest-working players in
the 60s he tirelessly looked for
positions like this where he could trap
even world champions with superior
knowledge
everything here is sound he didn't have
to do the work over the board he just
brought his ideas that's not to say that
poor guy asked he wasn't a good player
or a palooka FC couldn't win brilliant
games which he did several times it's
just that his marketing style was the
hard work that he put in his opening
preparation and that was one of the
things that led him to be so great
beluga ascii was known as a relatively
shy person he wasn't a very outgoing guy
and he mentioned one
time that he was his own worst enemy he
had some confidence problems both on and
off the chessboard
as he mentioned he said that a game of
chess with him could be relatively
random as he had the capacity code to
turn any candidate master into a world
champion at least in his own mind when
he was playing them so he would uh Nesta
mate opponents believing their ideas be
very unconfident about his own ideas and
it cost him a lot of chances it said
that that is the reason that he was
never strong enough to compete in the
World Championship match he came close
twice the first time was in the on 1977
I want to say I think I haven't known
about that the 1977 yeah candidate cycle
we're in the quarterfinals him he met
Enrique meking from Brazil and beat him
soundly but in the semi finals he lost
against corpse nine and the same thing
happened in 1980 where palooka is key
again in the quarterfinals lost against
I'm sorry he beat mikail tal in the
quarterfinals and he went on to lose
again to Kirchner and that was a big
joke it's considered that palooka a ski
he just played a little bit better in
the final game he would have challenged
Karpov for the world championship but
instead of that he choked cautionary
warning cautioning challenge Karpov for
the world championship title and Karpov
won again so you know that's like chick
that's how history goes down just one
game so we're going to take a look at
some of the games that made little guy
have ski really famous the first thing
we have to understand it the polo guy
have ski has a variation named after him
and it's one of the most sharp
complicated and misunderstood variations
of all time and even though we live in
the information
you know with computers and
supercomputers and engines and the blue
and all this garbage nobody knows if
it's sound or not it's that complex so
we're going to take a look at a game
that he played in one of the inner
zonals because of his tireless work over
you know homework and homework of chess
he was very well-suited for playing
incredibly sharp openings so he was
known as a top night or expert Kaluga
offski was one of the people that we
like really brought the night off to the
level that it is even now we know that
night off is one of the top defenses for
black and one of the reasons it's known
like that is because of palooka of his
work in this open the variation efore c5
Knight f3 d6 d4 takes takes Knight of
693 a six is known of course as the
knight of Sicilian out of that Bishop g5
and Bishop e3 are considered to be the
sharpest response especial g5 leading to
some of the craziest chess games ever
played after the movie six f4 b5 was
played and b5 which looks incredibly
aggressive is considered to be the
palooka offski variation of the Sicilian
Idol it is unbelievably risky it leads
to some gains that are incredibly sharp
and it's not games of the past of games
of four years ago
I mean Nakamura lost a game against one
how in this position a couple years ago
in bill and these are top top players of
the world of the world playing in this
variation perfect yeah this is the Beale
game well how big Nakamura with white in
this position and it's it's a game which
is really funny because if you ever see
the interview of Wang Hao when he
analyzes this this entire game he's it's
it's something like
yeah I was looking at this is this a
fixed X takes cheked cheked cheked X
then at the end I thought I'm okay and
he goes on like for 30 minutes analyzing
me and all the variations that he saw
and even I as a grandmaster I'm just
dizzy like listening to him analyzed
because he looked at so many variations
that I don't understand how it's humanly
possible to analyze so deeply so the
main problem with the move b5 looks like
he five just wins apiece
because after you take and you take then
this night is spent right but the idea
of the variation is that after Queen c7
this really weird-looking move actually
saves the piece the problem is that
after pawn takes f6 Queen e5 check
somehow or another recovers the piece
there is no way to defend the king and
the bishop at the same time even though
nowadays accepting the piece and giving
up the bishop is considered to be the
main line so this is considered to be
the most dangerous line I guess the
palooka askew variation but as I said
it's so complicated that nobody really
knows what's going on it's so
complicated that a lot of people just
don't want to play because it's it's
that messy
once in a while we'll get a couple of
nod jobs and they're like okay let's
play see what happens but it's not very
common
I think Nakamura tried to play it for a
while then he I don't know if he gave up
or people stopped going into it
something happened but okay we're going
to go back to 1979 this is before
computers before anything and palooka
asked is playing this in the riga
inter-zonal
and he's playing against Gruen fold
so you who the groom fold top top player
at the time he played Queenie to simply
defending the pawn 9 ft 7 castles and
knights e6 now a lot of people thought
that this variation was basically
suicidal because if you count how many
Tempe White's has of black and
considering how much development he has
on him
well it looks silly to play like this
but palooka offski had meticulously
analysed so many lines and he thought
that because of his superior pawn
structure as long as he survived the
incoming onslaught he would have good
counter chances and maybe even better
chances to set up something on the Queen
side as long as he didn't get made it in
the next 5 moves right so he had to be
really really really really careful also
it worked out in his favor that he
analyzed so much and his opponents well
they didn't know what they were doing
and how can you blame them I mean this
is something that the guys spend
hundreds of hours on 9 takes c6 Queen
takes assist Queen b3 was played pinning
this Knight and allowing the bishop to
join the fray with Bishop e2 f3 h h6 was
played Bishop h4 Bishop d7 now after
Bishop e2 polo guy FC didn't allow the
trade of the bishop so he retreated
Queen c7 ruk H e1 and notice how Beluga
yeskey here keeps ignoring the fact that
this pawns consistently hanging he just
never wants to take it he never ever
ever ever wants to take something that's
in the way of whites attack in this case
this pawn is protecting him from any
rook intrusion on the e-file
and it would cost him a full temple to
actually take that so he ain't
interested this pawn is not going to be
taken Knight c5 was played Queen h3 d4
and as in any good Sicilian battle we
got to the point where group filled
either had to let go of his initiative
and start retreating or he have to
sacrifice a piece and that's what makes
this kind of variations so fun and
pleasant to watch is
because it always comes down to that
does the piece sacrifice work or does
the fee stack rifice not work pretty
cool right so here if if he retreats
White's initiatives lost the Knights on
b1 it's not doing anything white blacks
going to follow up rooks e8 threatening
stuff on the C file and it doesn't seem
like White has any concrete ideas right
the brilliant plan of playing Queen e6
pawn takes Bishop h5 checkmate doesn't
work because a it's not checkmate
I can interpose and B this knight on c5
is defending e6 so there are no tricks
it seems like blacks just better instead
of group we'll play Knight b5 giving up
a full piece but hoping to get some
initiative out of this his point was
that after pawn takes Bishop takes b5
check bishop c6 was played it was the
only decent way of defending right what
other way can I defend against this
Chuck you play the move Queen f3 kind of
a little cunning move
all right the point is you cannot take
the Queen because you're pinned okay
let's try that again because you're
pinned here right and you cannot take
here because you're pinned here so in
this scenario how do you defend the
bishop
yes yes Luke CA but this loose is
instantly because after check takes
check takes rook the 8th it's checkmate
at the end right so there is no
possibility of defending against the
bishop you can't defend the bishop it
looks like it looks like blacks toast
and yes he comes up with the move Knight
b3 check like what well it's got a point
White has three legal for legal moves in
this position three of them loose and
the other one is just weird
so we're going to look at them one by
one first of all if pawn takes on b3 I
play Bishop takes b5 check so you don't
have time to take my rook you have to
defend against the Queen attacking your
king so if King b1 now I can simply move
my rook away and I'm up up peace
everybody agree with that yes good all
right
so this doesn't work for white if you
take with the Queen you lose the pin
again right on the diagonal so again I
can just take your piece and I'm a
poppies there are no immediate threat
there's nothing going on if a takes b3
which is not what was played but what's
the best move then the game becomes a
mess like a huge mess
rook a one check King D 2 now it's not
possible to take them b5 because I take
on a one
right but the intermediate move route
takes d1 check doesn't work either
because after rook takes d1 Bishop takes
b5 the move Queen a a check is still
lethal the king must move to d7 that's
the only move and after i simply retreat
the King to c1 black is left wondering
how exactly do I defend my King not you
could interpose the bishop but I just
take your rook and work it where else
can I go like what else can I do there's
nothing the King stuck right instead
black has to play the move in this
position Queen d7 check so white cannot
retreat the bishop because I take the
Queen right the Queen will just be left
hanging I cannot put the Queen on d3
because I can now trade and then take on
b5 with impunity because there is no
trick with Queen a check right now black
emerges up a piece instead he must play
Queen King III notice that if he plays
Keaney too I again take the Queen with
check right so you have no time to play
Bishop takes D seven instead King III
has to be played and then check again
and then King F four and then check
again and actually the evaluation of
this position is believe it or not about
equal there are some further variations
that need to be analyzed to fully
explain what's going on here but if
everything is calculated out this this
position was considered to go after many
trades into a draw
a shine game which looks ridiculous but
that's how HS works of course this looks
incredibly scary your kinks on f4 it's
getting checked and everything's hanging
right so Gruffudd was like nah not
playing that so I mean he played King b1
after by the way it said the legend goes
which is not that much larger it's
written down somewhere palooka ascii
played before after a one hour thought
he thought for one hour before he made
the move before he explained that he was
calculating the consequences of night b5
take stays here Queen f3 chucked a takes
b3 bouquet one King b2 and everything
that we just saw he spent one hour
analyzing that instead king b1 was
played
but now palooka asked his brilliant
resource comes like the question that
you who doubt grew fulfilled asks with
the move Knight b3 check is like ok so
what was the point right like okay you
give me a check but the point is that
the actually the knight retreats to a 5
and now it's defending the bishop that's
it that's it and then white up with down
a piece which is on a piece the bishops
defended it I have successfully defended
the bishop and that's it there's no more
threats after route d4 rooks see a
droopy one g5 cutting the bishop out of
the game check here Queen d3 Bishop e7
groom field tried on and on and on and
to be fair a palooka excuse technique
was
not the best in this game but eventually
okay he was up a piece and he won but I
mean brilliant right 93 check all these
variations and the ideas the King moves
I go back and I defend my bishop Wow
genius the guy was incredible and I
think one of his like most staple games
was this one he actually the funny thing
is that he planted a haenyeo tawdry one
of the first Grand Master from the
Philippines and a very strong
Grandmaster at that is several times now
tor is actually still alive and he's
still playing and I want to say that
this Olympia that just happened in Trump
sir I want to say that was his 27th
Olympiad in a row so the guys that guy's
been playing consistently for some time
and he saw his been the top of the top
of the top of the Philippine Chess
Federation until of course Wesley Saul
came around but that's a different
that's a different issue
so we're going to look at a game where
Polly guys could play it again story in
one of the most devastatingly
interesting games and brilliant again
this was all prep and he understood it
he didn't win because of prep but it
definitely helped up so d4 d5 c4 c6
Knight f3 Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 Bishop
g5 leaves us in one of the sharpest
variations of chess known as the BOD
Phoenix semi Slav after pawn takes c4 c4
b v e5 and you can already see that the
games like a mess right pawns are going
anywhere black took upon and c4 what's
not recovering it like what's going on
h6 then of course this knight is pinned
h6 Bishop h4 by the way palooka asked is
white g5 9 takes pawn takes Bishop takes
g5 9b d7 takes on f6 and this is all
known theory even though it looks super
weird blocks down a pawn but he'll
eventually maybe recover it and he wants
to really quickly play on the center
with Bishop e7 Queen b6 long castles
c5 so Bishop d7 G 3 C 5 T 5
and here look at what pulao guy as he
came up with the idea back then was the
96% good move because this pawn is
pinned Wickham if it moves this rook
dies not exactly like that more like
this something like that and the rook
dies right so you cannot move the pawn
and it looks like the point is lost
which looks really bad for blood for
white because if this pawn captures this
one well there's some huge pawn mass in
the center that looks really really
threatening but pulao gave scheme and he
didn't care he took on e6 so okay
Tora took the rook and he played a seven
all right he noticed Tori that if he
moves the bishop man Knight takes e5 is
strong because now if I take that Bishop
ninety-seven is checkmate
but what else to do I mean I do I cannot
comfortably defend the check because
then this check is powerful right yes
with 97 yeah you're gonna chest yeah
you're right yeah well 96 well the point
is that you cannot defend against 97
right so Tori sacrificed this fish up
and said okay if you take my bishop I'll
take it back probably with the pattern
of the rook or the king whatever
computer and I'm up an exchange right
I lost the rook but I lost the bishop
the pawn is still there blacks up the
exchange she's still pretty happy and
this is supposed to be a little bit
better for black but he came up with
this idea he's like I don't want that
Bishop h4 and the point was that after
Bishop h6 f4 he was literally going to
not do anything recovering material he
was just going to play the rest of the
game saying that this pawn chain locks
out the rook and locks out the king so
even though blacks awfully full rook he
can't exploit it he can't use it so b4
was played and it's like this guy just
didn't care he played rook t6 I was like
okay you're attacking my knight that's
cute I'll tack yours rook b8 was played
91 takes takes and here blacks up a rook
but he has no moves Tori was actually a
strong Grandmaster he found some
interesting ideas he realized if he
doesn't do anything he'll eventually
just get smothered so instead he played
95 with the idea that after Bishop c4 he
would sacrifice his knight in order to
free the rest of his pieces so 97 takes
takes but Beluga yes he wasn't done he
played rook f6 and notice how this root
bishop on this rook works so beautifully
and then this night is going to come in
an attack as well
ruk HF 893 Bishop b4 and total guy ask
you finally took on a six and with this
move you finally recovered material
parity he has is down the exchange but
has two points further and if we count
three plus two is five and the rook is
worth five so they're equal material but
it's clear that White has the winning
position he has a passed pawn on h4 his
bishops and monster black strokes are
not threatening anything and blacks
positions just a myriad of weaknesses so
after Ruby d8 the rook retain returned
to its post route d6 was played and as a
general rule when you're playing down
the exchange you want to keep your
remaining rook so in this case if you
only have one remaining and your
opponent has two rooks most of the time
you want to retain yours so here there's
no threat no trading of this the rugby
trades d4 and h5 Bishop d3 was played
which was a very good move trying to
trade off some pieces Knight d5 check
was quite strong King d6
takes on d4 now plug why didn't have a
choice he has to trade takes and Bishop
b3 which Apple oogah you have to
consider to be very inaccurate it was
better to take immediately and go into
the endgame with the past pawn he messed
this up a little bit but still after g4
King f4 g6 he won convincingly because
after pawn takes g6 pawn takes g6 there
would be no way of stopping the pawn
from promoting for example rook e8 check
King d2 Ruki 7 Bishop f7 followed by g7
g8 in panic mode
Tory played King III but after g7 King
c8 King F 1 getting out of some of the
mating ideas though he didn't have to he
could've played 86
d3 King g2 king of 4 h6
totally ran out of time but he's
completely lost he doesn't have any way
of preventing the pawns from simply
march
so kind of a very pretty kind idea below
galovski style in which he used the fact
that blacks material wasn't worth
anything because it couldn't participate
in the game so Booga ASCII you know he
was known as a player the preferred
really sharp openings he had incredible
opening preparation a theoretician there
was actually a 1994 tournament held in
Buenos Aires to commemorate his 60th
birthday and it was attended by Paula
Garr and Karpov and every player that
you can think of and it was a teen
tournament only the Sicilian was
playable in this tournament you had to
play the Sicilian in this event and it
was just really really cool yes no you
could actually play any Sicilian you
wanted so you and opal guy yes he was
famous for his night or variations he
was also proficient in some others so
that was a really cool event and he was
a supplier incredibly influential he
wrote a book called Grandmaster
preparation and grandmaster preparation
is a book that if you grab it right now
none of the analysis is relevant because
it's old but some there is there's a lot
of beauty in that book it's a very
personal capture of his analysis process
of how he came up with ideas of how he
prepared against opponents of how he put
his soul and his passion into work and
he always believed in analysis he always
thought that analyzing positions over
and over and over again would be the key
to success to a chess player in a quote
analysis is glittering for training it
is just here in analysis that capacity
for work perseverance and stamina are
cultivated
and this quality this qualities are in
truth necessary for a chess player as
running is for a marathon runner that it
was in the analysis and in the
consistent hard work that a player
became who he was and polo guy yeah he
was definitely the hardest working
player of them all he had many brilliant
victories as you can see he beat tall he
beat Tory he beat Petrossian he beats
miss love and this very nice win against
gold Coe was actually really really
pretty where he played Queen age six and
after 96 the finishing move 96 was
absolutely killer in this position you
cannot take the pawn because 9 take CA
but if you take the pawn of the knight
on d6 then rook takes c6 the rook not
only destroys the knight the defence
against Queen g7 checkmate but also
happens to defend against Queen takes f6
so after 96 our gurukul resigned fully
the guy asking if he got better nerves
and if he had like a stronger
psychological presence it's possible
that he would have become at least a
more serious contender to the World
Championship title but nobody ever
doubted Beluga yes be strong
you